bien difficile aujourd'hui je trouve sur
rescue ok c'est partir à taper du mmm et
envoyez les à dans du papier bulle de
préférence le pakistan aux orques éco
gestes en accord au plus tard à elle
m'en parlait pas du tout moi à moi c'est
bizarre non
arrêtez ça va trop vite laissez moi le
temps si mouflets responsable qui ajoute
une carrière là bas tu es à la brigue
les incendies je t'aime hop la merde
attendez moi je peux faire une tête
attend holla holla la sédition
appelez-moi zizou monga alors les
chapeaux des gages à temps et les mains
sur mes mails et enfin je propose sont
en jeu et je suis désolé des fois ya des
bébés en guerre c'est des adolescents se
maquille coude avec une couche mais
walcott s'est finie français j'ai fait
un score de merde à temps c'est parce
qu'on était en difficile donc du coup on
va se remettre
en face ils voient là ok c'est parti
cette fois on a ce côté les gars hop hop
hop et waimes ya ces sept pompiers
ah si j'ai pas de petits cadres employés
du hockey ça sans faire exprès ça
s'appelle un feuilleton wind en mer vers
la mer mr diallo c'est perdre et attrapé
au passage up
non ça dégage sa barre mais même avec
m'a pris pour des cons ou quoi les
collègues là pourquoi les rattraper
alors qu'on peut juste les envoyer comme
ça ah c'est vrai ou pas bref tout ça
parce qu'on s'amuse à boxer les bébés
[ __ ] aaa
sinon je suis paré là attendez attendez
attendez pousse pousse
ah j'ai perdu ma meuf
justement après l'annoncé a perdu ma
main pour sauver des vies pourquoi
salamé nsa un [ __ ] de kankan merde ça
multiplie la neige c'est quoi j'avais un
peu les gars je mène on va perdre la
face à sarcelles dit ok ok ok on arrête
les conneries on devient pompier
d'exception
[Musique]
ah ouais ok elle s'accroche et on t'aime
pas dans le camion rien et le on a sauvé
24 on a perdu 24
ça fait un bon ratio là ce qui va se
passer est qu'on va faire le second
level deuxième lame est parti alors là
c'est quoi ce délire
ah mon dieu une panique s'est crashé il
faut les sauver alors avant toute chose
on va pas se mentir si on peut boire un
peu d'eau pour s'hydrater
ça fait toujours plaisir aux quais
marseillais mais je vous savez ça en
moins de les poteaux en [ __ ] mais ça
fait un embryon sain pour un benêt
comment motiver j'attrape au revoir ses
amis d'alors sa petite robe à franges et
envoie là-bas tient à touba mais faites
péter ça va plus vite arrêté il ya trois
choses qui se passent à la fois qu'est
ce qu'on fait c'est debout et on prend à
aa je me suis je me suis fait les
cervicales j'en ai marre de jouer à
acheter ses jeux fincher blessés à leh
on se concentre fait péter les embryons
à un accident du travail
je suis à genoux je continue obaïdi moi
s'il vous plaît oui là - d'après je me
semble je me sens avec au revoir à dia
j'en ai mangé ce travail parce que j'ai
jamais aimé pompiers s'agit donc bien
voyez des bébés dans la famille c'est ça
qui nous coupent mouja on va t'envoyer
des bébés malgré ce terrible accident du
travail ce doigt fracturé ce quiz et le
pompier retourner au travail pour sauver
la vie des pauvres petits-enfants aux
falcons le prochain match mais un funk
moi je crois qu'on a eu en effet enfin
qu'on a su avec yoda oui oui à priori
oui mais moi à plat
alors la rangée juste le quidam
délicatement non non non non ah pardon à
mes liens d'un train de péter le studio
une casse son studio en jouant htc
veille c'est ça le truc mais franchement
je veux bien sauver des vies je viens à
accomplir ma mission mais un moment fait
un effort ok ok ok voir faire le niveau
1 et mais qu'on va faire un score de ou
sans regarder on selon séoul camion il
est dans notre mind on a ouvert notre
esprit on est bon allez fais pas tu es à
gros budget on a sauvé 15 ans a perdu
quinze mêmes égards techniques secrètes
on va jouer avec le pied pour les
envoyer ce sera beaucoup plus simple
c'est parti je mettrais de retourner
attention autant la chromatine merde
[Applaudissements]
oh
oui l'euro revenu le gagner sur ça
allait merci à tous d'avoir regardé
cette finale d'euro fincher dans la fois
un succès incroyable retourné
acrobatique in the truck servir camion
donc je suis donc laissé pas mal de ce
que vous appelez vos gars très vite dans
une prochaine mission de pompier ou une
mine posée une mission sans [ __ ] à
terme un projet neo partez vous bien sûr
tout le monde puisse
[Musique]